the birthday of the United States Army
I gave 24 years of my life as Service as
an army officer and I know what
dereliction of Duty looks like
secretary Alejandro mayarkas has been
willfully derelict in his duties as
Secretary of Homeland Security
he is disregarded his oath to the
Constitution By ignoring the basic
tenets of that Constitution
the disaster at our Southern border did
not happen because of weather anomalies
changes in the governments of 160
different countries
a sudden decrease in the resources of
Border Patrol
a sudden decrease in the budget of
Homeland Security or changes to the
immigration laws of the United States
the massive Millions upon upon millions
of people have crossed our Southern
border because the Secretary of Homeland
Security removed 89 policies from two
previous Administrations
the cause is simple
migrants tested the system they called
home and millions came because of the
secretary's Catch and Release policies
no detention immediate parole and the
drug cartels seized on the opportunity
they profit from using people people
who've paid them to overwhelm the border
patrol to sneak fentanyl into our
country you can't make an intellectual
argument for anything but that
and the effect on our nation has been
devastating
6.2 million encounters between our
northern and southern border 1.5 million
gotaways criminal aliens released into
the United States murderers released
into the United States rapists released
into the United States and the list goes
on and on and I'm not even talking about
the composition of the 1.5 million
godaways whom we know nothing about and
who intentionally avoided being caught
and released into our country
107 000 dead Americans in one year alone
to narcotics fentanyl Etc pouring across
our Southern border Alejandro mayorcas's
policies are the cause of all of this
unfortunately it gets worse
today the United States Congress under
the leadership of speaker Kevin McCarthy
and the Republicans myself as chairman
of the committee of Homeland Security
and the members of our committee begin a
five-phase deep dive into the causes and
Secretary mayorkas's orchestration of
this tragedy
we have provided a document
that details the topics of the five
phases and provides a small glimpse into
what we will be looking into in Phase
One the dereliction of Duty phase
what we know right now is that secretary
mayorkas has either violated or
subverted at least 10 laws passed by the
Congress of the United States
he has ignored multiple court orders to
cease and desist his activities
the blatant disregard for the
Constitution of the United States which
states that the United States Congress
passes the laws and the executive branch
executes those laws is just scratching
the surface to the harm secretary Mary
arcus's dereliction of Duty has done to
our country
secretary mayorkas has blatantly lied to
the United States Congress under oath
on multiple occasions and lied to the
American people at least 58 times
majorca's dereliction of Duty has placed
the safety of Americans second to his
own personal agenda with hundreds of
thousands of dead Americans due to the
poison he has allowed the cartels to
bring into our country with the deaths
of sheriff's deputies executed by
criminal aliens autistic young women
raped
children dead after exposure to fentanyl
on the floor of a vacation property who
in America
can feel safe with secretary mayorkas's
policies
this tragedy has impacted the migrants
also with 30 plus percent of women
reporting sexual assaults almost 2 000
dead migrants at our Southern Border in
just over two years
children lost to a life of forced labor
inside the United States of America and
countless others forced into criminal
activity to pay their cartel debt his
policies have resulted in a humanitarian
crisis this country has never seen
he even admitted his own incompetence
which is also a form of dereliction of
Duty by admitting to the United States
Senate he didn't understand the basic
strategy of the cartels that he is
confronting
he admitted He was unaware of the
tracking systems used by the cartels
what general in the United States Army
could have such a lack of knowledge of
the enemy he is facing and still remain
commanding troops
he's also failed the men and women we've
given him the privilege to lead lying
about their behavior to support a
political narrative
pushing them out of the jobs that they
signed up for
cing them to do impossible missions
leading to the highest suicide rate ever
amongst CBP
and the most egregious of all
at least to this former Soldier
secretary Marcus has put the National
Security of the United States at risk
terrorists suspected terrorists and
enemies of our nation have flooded
across our borders
we've previously reported the numbers
for the terrorists and the terrorist
watch list
but I want to break a little news today
you thought the Chinese spy balloon was
bad
this chart here
depicts a massive surge in Chinese
Nationals many of whom are military aged
men
y with known ties to the pla
ties to the CCP who have crossed our
Southern border and just been released
by secretary mayorkas into the United
States
we have no idea who these people are and
it's very likely using Russia's template
of sending military personnel
into the the into Ukraine China is doing
the same in the United States we already
know that there's a Chinese listening
station just across 90 miles of ocean
in Cuba that frustrates the American
people
just like the Spy balloon frustrated
Americans
how about 10 000 Chinese Nationals
illegally crossing into the United
States being released into our country
this fiscal year
today's hearing will begin the process
of digging into all of the details the
cause and effect of Alejandro mayorcas's
dereliction of Duty
I hope the American people will listen
intently I hope to press will report
this honestly
I hope the president of the United
States the commander-in-chief charged
with the security and protection of this
country will listen he can't possibly
know of all of these failures of
mayorkas and have not fired him already
again thank you for being here I will be
followed by the chairman of the Border
subcommittee uh chairman Higgins
thank you chairman Greene
secretary May orchest's failures
have been
clearly felt across the country and in
every sovereign state
he's he's to be held accountable
because he's sworn oath
to protect
the sovereignty of our nation
and serve in the capacity as secretary
from the Department of Homeland Security
which includes an advisor capacity to
the president if the president's
policies are
or the president's agenda
ultimately become injurious to the
nation
it's up to that executive level
secretary
to advise that president
we've given secretary mayorkus ample
opportunity
to step back
from the injury that he's brought Upon
Our Country
we've we've asked him
Point Blank please resign
to save the nation the pain of the
reveal of your failure
and yet
he stubbornly has remained in place
continuously comes before Congress and
lies
we've had countless interactions wherein
clearly
we've revealed
colossal failure and the disintegration
of our sovereignty at the southern
border the horrific impact
upon our nation in fact
it it's it's quite reasonable
to look at our current ERA
at this point in American history
and
and consider how the next generation
will reflect upon this time
secretary mayorkus's failures have
brought generational trauma
Upon Our Country
the next generation will look back and
say this what was America like before
the Biden majorcus era
and what is it like after
this is how
this is how painful
his Service as Secretary of the
Department of Homeland Security has been
to our country
so we're going to judiciously and calmly
patiently
lay out the case and the details
regarding secretary mayorkus's
dereliction of Duty we take no pleasure
in doing so
my colleagues on the committee under
chairman Green's leadership
we recognize this as a solemn affair
but the American people deserve Safety
and Security at the very least
American citizens expect our Sovereign
borders to be secure
and when we Face a failure of this level
this um
this easily recognized repeated failure
with the course of over two years
with secretary mayorkas we must act and
constitutionally that action begins
in the Department of Homeland Securities
records and the Homeland Security
committees reveal of the failures we'll
clearly Point them out over the course
of the coming weeks and months
and we believe that America will
will come to concur
with our assessment that secretary
mayorkas
has completely failed his nation and
should be removed from office through
the Congressional process or preferably
by his own will
or perhaps as president
would act
but we have to stop the
arterial bleed at our Southern border
ladies and gentlemen
we're losing our country down there
I yield
to my colleague representative Lee and
thank you all for being here today
thank you clay
for more than two years
Americans have endured the negative
effects of this administration's failed
border policies that have resulted in
National Security
humanitarian and Public Safety disasters
at our Southern border this crisis has
left imprints across the country causing
every community in America to become a
border community
Mexican cartels
transnational gangs human trafficking
groups and other criminal organizations
have taken advantage of our open
Southern border engaging in a wide array
of criminal activity here in the United
States
among the vilest of the criminal conduct
that these groups have conducted here
within the United States is human
trafficking and the exploitation of
children
last month we saw the heartbreaking loss
of a migrant child who arrived in the
United States without a parent or
guardian and died in federal custody in
Safety Harbor not far from my
congressional district
a Florida grand jury report in March
revealed alarming details about the
office of refugee resettlement's role in
the trafficking of minors the report
details critical failures both in
screening minors and in screening their
sponsors they serve to empower drug
cartels and criminal organizations
putting those who cross our border in
danger of being trafficked exploited or
killed
responsibility for these atrocities
Falls squarely on secretary mayorkas who
has direct hand in the open border
policies that have led to empowering
these criminals and the humanitarian and
legal crisis we presently endure
to make matters worse fentanyl is being
trafficked freely across our Southern
border coming into American communities
at such a rate that it has become the
leading cause of death for people ages
18 to 45. recently in my own community
sheriff's deputies seized 11 pounds of
Fentanyl and our state's attorney
general announced that in recent months
enough fentanyl had been seized to kill
every single Floridian
congress's responsibility here is very
serious
securing our border
enforcing our laws
taking steps to stop unchecked illegal
immigration
this is the humanitarian thing to do and
it is our responsibility to ensure the
safety of our communities across America
when we fail to enforce our laws we
Empower criminals
today the homeland security committee is
here to share with you our plan to
review and investigate secretary
mayorkas and the failed policies that
have led to these atrocities it is our
responsibility to get answers for the
American people we are a nation of laws
and we expect this nation's leaders to
follow and to enforce those laws House
Republicans made a promise to keep our
nation safe we passed the most
comprehensive border security Bill to
date and now we will examine the facts
and we will examine the failures of this
Administration and we will provide
answers to the American people at the
end of the day our constituents back
home and all across this country deserve
a nation that is secure a nation that
follows its laws and to feel safe in
their own communities thank you
with that we will take your questions
and I appreciate my other colleagues
joining us today we'll start right here
yeah what evidence you have that some
Chinese Nationals crossing the border
are connected to the CCP or PLA and then
another question what impeaching
mayorcas actually fix the problem or
does the rot go deeper within VHS
the policies are very clearly secretary
mayorkases and he's been made aware
multiple times of what what has happened
the Senate's hearings too have been very
comprehensive with him pointing out his
own failure to understand what's going
on at the border Etc but they've
educated him in the process and he has
not acted so I believe that the the
major
fault lies with Alejandro mayorcas in
terms of the verification that the
individuals being released into the
United States come from are half ties to
the pla it came from a sector Chief and
I I'm going to leave it at that at this
point we have a classified briefing
coming up on it in the very near future
right here thank you chairman green
um
do you
think or do you plan that for the GOP to
use the Appropriations process to place
contingencies
on DHS funding given the Border crisis
you know the the
my history as a soldier
um informs my decisions on this uh when
a when a
rifle platoon leader isn't using his
machine guns well you don't take the
machine guns away from him you teach
them how to use them or you hold them
accountable or you find a new platoon
leader
in this case we're not going to take the
resources away from CBP they need they
need the Appropriations to do their job
in fact
the border patrol specifically has been
leaving in droves because the pay
discrepancies between them and other
members of DHS
so we actually in our uh
bill that representative Lee talked
about plused up a bonus for those guys
because look they they're doing yeoman's
work the last thing we're going to do is
hurt those guys we want to help we want
to do more for them more than the
secretary's done we're not talking about
taking away research I'm more I'm sorry
I should be specific
um more like placing
um contingencies on the secretary and
like in his office kind of you know in
order to no we're gonna we're gonna hold
the secretary accountable for his
failures and uh you know we're going to
go about it that way right here
you know we haven't even gotten to that
word that process our goal here is we're
starting with what you have here and
we're going to get more information
about the failures of this uh this
secretary
and you know when we're done
um
we'll make a recommendations to the
Judiciary Committee uh one way or the
other and we'll see what they have to
say
yeah
this would need to be referred to
because
seating can you talk about your
coordination or conversations with
chairman Jordan about your investigation
this would eventually be handed over to
yeah I've just kept Jim our chairman
Jordan informed in what we're doing and
you know we as chairman sit down and and
talk about what we're doing amongst all
of the Committees and sometimes there's
a little overlap you know so you have to
deconflict that uh like like everywhere
we all want to kind of
take care of our stuff and but so
chairman Jordan and I talk weekly about
that stuff also chairman Comer you know
the three of us kind of looking at some
of this stuff so in the back yes ma'am
yeah what do you say to Democrats who
say you're trying to kick off
impeachment based on policy differences
and then I was also hoping you could
explain a little further what the legal
basis would be for dereliction of Duty
well the legal basis is the violation of
the law lying to Congress those are all
der election of Duty they qualify by the
definition of their election of Duty
whether you look at University of
Cornell or uh Cornell University's
definition in their Law Department or
you look at the United States military's
definition in the uniform code of
military Justice what this guy's done
you know no officer gets to lie to his
Superior no officer gets to lie to his
uh you know equal you can't do that
that's a dereliction of your duty you
can't
um fail to do your job you know his job
is to secure the border of the United
States he's failed to do that and if you
think 107
000 dead Americans and 6.2 plus 1.5
that's 7.7 if I'm doing my math right
million more people
30 something states are smaller than
that into the United States
sapping the resources of communities
the the the the parents in Yuma Arizona
having to go 200 miles to deliver their
babies because their Hospital's
overwhelmed
um the dead Americans from you know the
crime that happens think about Sheriff's
deputy I mean
the United States is not secure his job
is to secure the United States he's
failed that's a dereliction of his duty
I don't see
I don't see a I mean I I guess I don't
understand the question because when I
think of a hundred and seven thousand
dead Americans in one year I don't think
this is a policy thing either is
successful in protecting the American
people or he isn't and he clearly isn't
so
and I want to give the opportunity for
my colleagues if y'all have questions
for them yes sir right here for
Americans that are at home watching this
right now
um what do you have to say to them about
the timing of this announcement and
really ramping up this investigation and
why didn't this happen in January
February right after Republicans well
our priority at first uh was to get to
the border and see what was going on and
we took our border boot camp down there
and then we did a hearing on the border
and then we realized the first thing we
had to do is write the bill right so I
mean we had to do take action to
actually secure the border so we passed
and that that was not without you know
some challenges getting that all put
together as you guys appropriately
reported but once that was done we
immediately started directing our
attention to holding America's
accountable so I think our timing has
been about right it's it was an accident
the that today you know we we did this
and put it on the calendar for the 14th
and then I realized that's the birthday
of the United States Army perfect uh you
know to talk about dereliction of Duty
after having served for 24 years I mean
I took the oath uh when I was 17 at West
Point to defend the Constitution of the
United States not it's very interesting
the oath and Marcus's oath is the same
right
it's not to the geography of America
it's not to the flag it's to the
Constitution the idea of America and to
the way the Constitution orchestrates
how the government is to work
that is Congress writes the law it's a
brilliant separation of powers
they execute the laws mayorkas has
written the laws he's undone the laws
without anything in Congress having ever
been passed so
much
I I would I will I'll give you a
prediction and I'm not usually uh prone
to doing that when asked by reporters if
I should give a prediction but I would
say it's probably going to take about 11
to 12 weeks
um you know that's our our front end
sort of look but what we will hold the
Liberty to do is if there's something
else that we need to dig into delaying a
phase
you know the one that's really going to
be challenging from a fact-finding basis
is the financial phase
understanding the costs because we're
trying to go to county jails that have
illegals that they're having to house in
the local County taxpayers are having to
you know foot the bill for that we're
going uh to hospitals All Over America
and trying to document the uncompensated
health care costs that are just going to
be transferred to taxpayers
so we want to put a price tag on this
and it's that may take longer than what
we're predicting it'll take but we'll
take whatever time we need
right here I gave you one already oh
they're in they're in the packet that we
get yeah
thank you I want to ask them so you said
I know there's a lot of questions about
impeachment you said you haven't gotten
to that word that process but I mean one
of your own members Margaret Taylor
green filed an inquiry last week I asked
her yesterday and she said the hearing
today she wants it uh to be the start of
the conference getting on board so is
there a discrepancy in terms of I don't
know what timeline your members want on
your committee and
I would I would think that you guys are
you know it's intuitively obvious that
Republicans are independent thinkers
right from the past few weeks I mean
would you agree I would I would say it's
intuitively obvious to the Casual
Observer that Republicans are
individualists and we we think
independently we're not robots being
told by a speaker how to vote
um and so I there are many people with
differences of opinions about this and
uh but you know I'm in a leadership
position and from my leadership position
the direction of our committee is to get
to the facts so
how many we got time for maybe one or
two more is that right where are we
doing okay right here now obviously
you're critics of my orchids but you're
also creating some president by
Insurance
in fact no longer the DHS secretary the
President Biden's going to appoint that
person sure how how do you have
confidence confidence President Biden to
find somebody who can actually fill that
role and how will removing my orcas
actually fix our problems
yeah look all I know today is what I can
make a decision on today and I have a
responsibility to the people of America
this guy's failing he's put Americans at
risk I mean look at that chart look at
those first seven past several years
very statistically insignificant
difference right look at the last year
that this fiscal year I mean there's
something going on here
all on May arcus's watch
threatening the National Security of the
United States God's got to go
okay I mean he we're going to hold him
accountable and that's if the president
picks another guy that does this kind of
stuff we'll do what we have to do there
too
Mr chairman the committee has like so
much on its plate in addition into all
of these border issues and issues with
the secretary I know you're ramping up
work on cyber security and FEMA and you
have said you want to overhaul the
entire department how are you going to
get all that done we're you know six
months in we got a great we got a great
Bill done
check box on the first one we're
starting the accountability of mayorkas
and simultaneously we're working on the
Cyber stuff right now you know one of
the things and I don't think I've
actually said this in the Press but one
of the things we want to do is create
something very similar to the ROTC
program
for cyber Security Professionals
and we think we we've got a way to pay
for it but we're 700 000 cyber Security
Experts short in this country
um and so yes I think I
I'm not I can't juggle
but I can juggle if you know what I mean
so
um
I mean
we'll get it done
other questions maybe one more any for
these guys
somebody want to answer you
we'll let you we'll come back to you and
that'll be it thank you very much
chairman
um
ultimately do you think the buck stops
with the president you know I know he's
saying no to net or no at the moment for
impeaching May orchest but what about
you know impeaching Biden or you know
and not impeaching by how to hold by an
accountable sense you know the bug
should do that the bug usually stops
with the president
well very clearly there's a concern
about that we're going to dig into the
policies of of uh the secretary and uh
we're going to hold him accountable
um you know it was I think I think the
American people
um getting educated on this looking and
seeing if some of this has been directed
from the president I mean maybe we find
out that we'll act
um but right now we know the decisions
being executed from the secretary to the
field
are what's causing the problem and and
that's where we're going to focus our
attention today now again we may
discover that the president directed all
this and that's the case and we'll cross
that bridge when we get there
my guess is honestly what in in my
observations of President Biden he
probably doesn't know all the stuff
we're going to show
in this report and I hope
when he hears all this when he sees all
this
um that he'll act responsibly
and take care of the problem
so all right guys thanks for being here
appreciate y'all